the one-year anniversary of the january
6th insurrection has passed but a new
collection at the smithsonian is
documenting how the day will be
historically preserved for future
generations the exhibit is still in the
early stages congressional correspondent
nicole killian got a glimpse and sat
down with lawmakers who whose memorable
actions have inspired part of the
curation
there's not a day that goes by when i'm
at the capitol where i don't think about
it it's still hard for new jersey
congressman andy kim to shake the images
of january 6. i remember walking into
the house oh into the rotunda and
it just my heart sank so his instinct
kicked in i just started to to clean up
there was a lot of just trash i mean
clothing
flags
what really compelled me to do it was
when my mother brought me to show me the
capitol building so it was personal very
i i
i hurt so much and i just remember
thinking like is there
anything i can do to try to have our
country move forward on this and i
didn't want to see a sunrise on a broken
capital
the image of kim in his blue j crew suit
instantly went viral and is now part of
a collection that will eventually go on
display at the smithsonian you don't
always associate political history with
clothing claire jerry is curator at the
museum of american history which
unveiled some of its items from
political signs retrieved right after
the riot to law enforcement badges and a
slashed bulletproof vest
how do you make this more than just a
terrible moment in history
well one of the ways we've done that i
think is by looking at other types of
events it is i think incumbent upon us
for future historians researchers and
for the american people to say there
were a lot of things happening this day
there's a lot of things that happen in
history and not all of them are easy to
talk about do you think congress has
healed no not at all in fact has become
in some ways a
moment that has divided us even further
maybe that exhibit can be a first step
i think certainly
understanding the truth of that day
needs to be a first step you cannot have
reconciliation unless you have the truth
to set the country free for cbs saturday
morning nicole killian washington